folks Jo de R Roa here I got some live
dates coming up I'd like to tell you
about why not uh I'm doing a special
show on November 9th at the KGB Bar New
York City as part of the New York Comedy
Festival the show's called selected
readings where I'm going to be reading
excerpts from my audio book The
Penthouse papers released on uh a
special thing records and I'm also going
to be reading some other stuff I've had
published over the years I'm looking
forward to that then I'm hitting the big
open road getting out of my own town
where I live and I'm coming to you with
what I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
live the new hour very proud of this
show November 11th hitting Philadelphia
PA theater of the Living Arts November
17th Pittsburgh PA at Bottle Rock at
Social Hall November 18th Buffalo New
York theater at senica 1 the 30th of
November Denver Colorado at the summit
December 1st Phoenix Arizona at the
Crescent Ballroom and December 3rd Salt
Lake City Utah at the soundwell folks
we're adding dates all the time but for
these days dates and ones we might add
later you can go to joa.com for Ticket
links and show information and of course
if you are in New York City and you want
to check out my establishment Joey roses
come on down we're open 7 days a week
11:30 a.m. every day we open those doors
for affordable booze and delicious
affordable sandwiches Joey roses nyc.com
what's up guys real quick tour dates are
on sale right now at salvano comedy
uh there's tons of cities up there
tomorrow night if you're watching us
right now on hey bab tomorrow night I am
in Bowling Green Kentucky on Friday
Cincinnati on Saturday and Toledo on
Sunday there's still some tickets
available so get those uh following that
we're going to be in wils Bear
Pennsylvania and Wilmington Delaware
then we're doing mon Savannah and Athens
Georgia and so on and so forth there's a
big Illinois run in November leading up
to my comedy special at the Vick in
Chicago on December 1st and 2nd the
second sold out as you guys I hopefully
know uh and so we added two shows on the
first all will be taped and all if you
have a ticket to any of those shows
you'll be eligible to win uh a flight
hotel and trip to the set of Impractical
Jokers I'm choosing one ticket out of
those four shows uh December 1st is
still on buds they com to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools going
to fight but only one food can be right
taste
buds hey taste buddies welcome to t a s
e buds we got a special guest in the
house how you doing my friend I'm great
Rob iser is here uh he you were recently
a guest on hey babe as well sir uh you
were in town we were so happy you took
the time to there's a travesty the the
last pod we were on because uh we
started a pod and it was a mixup on the
timing and then he came in when once we
started then the Pod was amazing super
funny but then they started doing major
major major construction right outside
this wall and uh we had to do it through
the construction but uh look I think
that now things have changed now it's a
bad day today no I think this is good
now now we're on time now we're on time
and there's I feel like I'm on track for
the first time right now today I've had
a quite a morning at my home you've had
quite a morning quite a describe your
morning to us please uh it was all stuff
and dealing with uh the purchase of
something and uh it's been a uh absolute
upside down
Nightmare and uh you know there you go
that's where we're at you still deal why
do you why do you say the purchase of
something instead of saying what it is
sorry I'm just adjusting I don't know
this is good this is good for
him he misses the noise from The
Constructor he's mixing it up a little
all right so yeah I said it on yeah I'm
buying a house and it has been a
whirlwind roller coaster I don't want to
get into the details but uh I don't
think
any yeah you don't want to think anybody
what I don't I don't know I don't know I
I don't know where you're going with it
I don't know if it's like if it's
minutia that you want to get into or Top
Line I don't want to get into any of it
at all it's just buying a house is the
worst thing I mean God bless you that
can that you're in a position to do it's
a good problem to have but anytime I've
ever purchased a property which is only
twice okay uh and and all first time in
2015 and now great with this place I got
to tell
you a nice building uh it's it was it
was nightmarish you you ever buy a
property or buy a home or anything I'm a
New Yorker I lived in one-bedroom
apartments my whole [__] life you
know two bed I've had two bedrooms or
one bedrooms always renting yeah I'm I'm
I got I got I've never owned the call
are wow nothing I'm 38 now God bless man
I I started to panic with the apparent
crumbling of society that I should buy
some property yeah yeah I almost got I
got a sword with that you know but like
I couldn't go full house but yeah I
definitely got I got stuff to like tase
people different kind of tasers you know
I told uh yeah I love the you I love
this [__] hit the fan you bought a house
and he bought a sword yeah and my
friends are like yo what's a sword SW
going to do I'm like well if somebody if
you see two people come in one has a
sword you're going to go with the like
they're going to go with the other one
I'm like so it buys me some time also I
would take a sword over like even for
home protection I would take a sword
over a bat I've seen people absorb the
bat a bat swing you oh they can get and
then can or they hold it in yanking but
with a sword it's like Hand That Rocks
the Cradle remember that he's holding
the baby oh my god wow that was like
Rebecca
deor hand that rock the cradle
right was sick yeah that was made
Seinfeld references oh yeah when the
lady I'm Rebecca Deon so funny uh I yeah
I said I have another podcast called
we'll see you in hell and Pat Walsh is
the I co-host it with him and he's one
of my best friends and I said to we were
talking the other day about all this
stuff and I said to him I go dude I'm
I'm about three days away from answering
my front door with a rifle like yeah
like I'm in the stand you who is it what
do you want like like [__] is so crazy
younger it used to be like oh those are
crazy people now when I see someone like
you know when there was all those like
riots everything people are standing
outside their house with guns I'm like
good for what do you mean those are like
yeah of course he suggested he suggested
I get a rocking chair and L lie it
across my leg a shotgun I think you're
may be dealing with something else
then uh yeah man it's uh anyway it's
been a hell of a morning for me it's
been a hell of a morning for you it's
been a hell of a morning for you got
here what 4 hours or twoo early I got
here had to do another podcast but I
told him like I I haven't worked in 15
years I'm great at killing time like I
could kill time with the best one like
if that was a sport I'd be the
guy yeah the uh I got thank God you
could have been anyone else today thank
God it was you interesting fact about
Rob that I that that Lit me up in a
great way uh and I was not on the show I
was on nearly to the amount that you
were on The Sopranos but you mean as a
main character yes I yeah I was not a
comparison not nearly as much I didn't
play a little boy the show uh no but you
were you have never except for the
premieres seen The Sopranos and I was on
better Calla and outside of the
premieres I I've never seen better call
saw I never saw breaking bad and I told
them that in like the fourth season and
everybody was like what and I was like
yeah I've never watched it man you
didn't feel like you needed any but
backstory would help I don't need any
back story prequel that's smart you
don't want to throw [__] in there that's
actually smart that's how that's what I
said to them and they were like all
right well it's good it's working so
good job but you've never I don't want
to talk about me you've never seen The
Sopranos yeah no again at the premieres
you sit down and they show it everyone
and you watch it but also you have to
remember when the show started I was 12
133 like I didn't care you know what I
mean I wasn't like oh what is like I
wasn't
I would have thought the opposite I
would have thought at 12 you get into a
TV show on HBO you're like you're like I
would be like oh my God I got to watch
this every week oh yeah no I was like I
was 12 13 I wanted to like hang you know
I want to like hang with my friends and
do like what like you know what's going
on at school and girl like I was just
getting girls like you know what I mean
I wasn't like oh you know Tony Sero and
poly walnuts like before that had you
had something anywhere near that caliber
whatsoever or you started AC even
younger than that right yeah so I I
started when I was six and I had done
commercials and then I did like SNL like
I did like little itty bitty things I
did like I think I did a movie I did
like this weird so I did this TV show
called Ted the head where the main
character was just a head like was that
the guy with his you looked at his
conscious Herman's head no that was
Herman's head no no yeah and he was just
like on a desk like at a school and
everybody came in and like you it was
wild it was like some Nickelodeon thing
that sh was dope oh wow you knew that
yeah I was a little kid yeah I love that
[__] wow that's like the that's like a
one of one Nickelodeon was doing the
coolest most offbeat artsy [__] The
Adventures of Pete and Pete yeah wasn't
CL Clarissa Explains at all was
Nickelodeon oh wow yeah might they were
doing the coolest [__] you might be
going ahead of me because I remember you
can't my big thing is you can't do that
on television yeah that was like
literally like the thing to watch like
if you didn't see
that was it I have searched high and low
for a box set of you can't do that on
television and you can't find it and the
show is high and low you say high and
low and side to side front back and side
to side the uh they've been the show was
extraordinarily controversial you know
like if you go back like there's a
recurring sketch is the the guy that
tortures the
kid he has a kid I think it's the kid
think of Different Strokes when they
took the bike shop in no no a recurring
sketch on you can't do that on
television was like a gapo guy because
the one old that guy played the guy yes
yes like a firing squad gu but then he
had another one where he had a dungeon
and he had this kid Kevin I think his
name was chain to the wall and that was
like the sketch it's even I remember
that dude with the I remember all this
now that you're playing it what do you
think's in the burgers I think remember
you remember the show well oh dude this
was I mean getting slimed was like the
ultimate dream I remember the main kid's
name was Alistair was it this uh wasn't
what's her name in it um I go down on
you in a theater atan wasn't she on this
she did right W yeah I remember the
lockers when they would come out of the
lockers to talk to each other they Nam
they called the main chick moose her
nickname was moose but
why I always thought it was like was she
a big gal not really but I always
thought it was kind of like a like that
was kind of the joke was like you know
you're you're a healthy gal moose oh was
she healthy that's what they say about
you know what I mean no I don't think no
by by normal standards no I'm saying
though I think that was the joke dude I
would love to just smoke some weed and
watch this dude that's why I've searched
high and low for the damn box I can't
find
it uh yeah man um so remember Kids
Incorporated yep do you remember that I
remember that name but I don't remember
what it was Kids
Incorporated k i d s kid you got the
yeah I did too many drugs I don't
remember [__] I know I don't remember
anything well this was I mean this was
when I we were kids though I got I got a
I got a blast in the you're probably to
Young for this right this was like I
this was like the Beatles bro yeah this
was the no I'm not kidding and there's
famous people in this too that later
became solo famous artist I I forget who
but it's um someone some right
there Gibson
or see I was like my shoe was that's
that's that's who it was wait that was
Fergie that was Fergie bro shut up yes
dude yes that's that's
F oh wow even then well Fergie's always
been a little risque is what I'm saying
yeah yeah yeah that's so funny um that's
crazy I got one for you Rob you're
probably too young for this ready for
this ready turkey TV do you remember
turkey TV is Dave Kier hosted it no oh
wow oh no Dave Kier hosted out of
control okay remember he go cut it out
cut well that's what he did on the Full
House baby that came he did it first was
already I think it was from his standup
okay that's how he got the audition
right he just came in and threw that
down we go cut it out yeah out of
control that's all you had to do back in
the day to be a legend you do one little
thing now you're 87 hours I me it's
crazy well speaking of that's full
circle cuz didn't he isn't it popular
legend that the go going down on you in
the theater was about Dave K yeah yeah
the whole the whole jacked Little Pill
the whole album no that's that's what
the rumor was the whole album was about
him there is the whole
album what did Dave
Kier Mo said that she had to that she
had inspir art in a
theater I'm going to add another layer
of icing to this ready yeah big J claims
big J oakerson our friend and very funny
comedian I'm getting calls from Comics
left and right Tino and then Annie
Letterman okay I get calls from Comics
saying you went bat
[__] so listen to this big J oerson yes
friend of the show friend in life claims
that he was at J for Laughs Montreal The
Comedy Festival and he was at a party in
a hotel suite and Dave Kier was there
and he said he was talking to e and he
said hey dude I gotta ask you like is it
about is is uh what you ought to know is
that song actually about you and he said
Dave Kier goes oh come on man and
stormed
off wow like got really pissed and
walked away I I I so that's a yes you
could you could imagine you could
imagine you can imagine that that means
that that's the thing he hears the most
every single like he can't escape it no
he can't that's what oh come on and and
store you can't escape it but also you
would think you'd come full circle and
like came to grips with like all right
people asked me this it's like Yo dude
cool down I know he broke it down on Jim
and Sam did are we allow are we allowed
to I think so
okay it's you know Ghostbusters full
house or any of this stuff and you're
dead seconds he just storms out lanis
Moret rumors start rearing their ugly
head are you going like I really I don't
need this out there right now or are you
like yeah it is what it is it was what
it was you know we dated and she was
writing all that that Jagged Little Pill
stuff during that time and and I never
saw this you know angry white girl thing
that she's you know that people have
kind of coined her as I never saw that
she was funny she was sweet she was
super intelligent super talented um so I
never I never saw
that you know that was 95 when Jagged
Little Pill came out and uh I started
here's the story I'm driving in Detroit
and I've got my radio on and I hear the
hook for you ought to know come on the
radio and I'm like wow this is a really
cool hook and then I start hearing the
voice I'm like wow this girl can sing
and I had no idea you know that that
this was the record and I gave someone a
cross and then I and then I was like uh
listening to the lyrics going oo oh
no oh I can't be this guy and I went to
the record store bought the CD and I
went and I parked on a street and I
listened to the whole record and there
was a lot of familiar stuff in there
that her and I had talked about like
your your shake is like a fish you know
I'd go hey dead fish me you know and we'
do this dead fish handshake and and so I
started listening to it and I thought o
I think I may have really hurt this
woman and that was my first thought and
so years later we
reconnected and uh she couldn't have
been sweeter and I said
when people ask me about this
relationship a whole album he's like I
think I might have so she was really
sweet about it she was kind um I'll tell
you the kind of person she is yeah she
was Dave when you ask her about it she's
like I'm banging Ryan Reynolds Dave I
don't care say whatever you want she
actually drove to Detroit with her
guitar and sat with my sister playing
songs and singing to my sister in the
hospital wow that's the kind of human
being is so I've never had anything bad
to say about her she's lovely what uh
now when you were in that theater that
she referenced as what movie were you
watching you know you thank you Jim you
do that uh you do that popcorn cup trick
one time and it backfires on
you that's the question everybody wanted
to ask did you know this what the entire
sopran series based on John
Stamos folks do you like going to live
events but you don't like getting those
tickets way in advance well we're cut
from the same cloth and that's why I
like game time I really like game time
they're URL
gametime.co go check them out there uh
here's what they're doing for you
they're taking the worry out of buying
tickets for the next big event it's fast
and easy way to buy all your tickets for
whatever event it is sports music comedy
whatever you want to go to they can help
you out last minute tickets Flash Deals
Zone deals uh it's easy to find and buy
the tickets for every kind of event in
your area they're giving you views from
all the seats in the venue so you can
see exactly what it's going to look like
where you're sitting and they've got a
low price guarantee that says if you
find tickets for less money uh after you
purchase in the same row or SE and
section is yours um they're going to get
they're going to credit you 110% of the
difference you can't really beat that
this is a pretty Carefree stressfree way
to get tickets when you want to buy them
how you want to buy them and for the
best deal possible so take the guest
work out of buying tickets with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account use code taste buds for $20
off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem the
code what's that code it's t s t bu DS
for $20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed folks I like
meat better yet I like a deal on meat
and and who's giving me that deal on
meat butcher box butcher box butcher box
delivering the great meat at a great
price to your front door how great is
that 100% grass-fed B free range organic
chicken pork raised crate free and wild
caught Seafood all of it humanely raised
no antibiotics no added hormones right
to your doorstep free shipping always
curated and customized box plans that
means you can go with what they picked
out to think goes together for you or
you you make your own thing up you got
options here I just think it's great I
don't think you can beat butcher Box's
prices uh I think their prices across
the board and their quality across the
board is unmatched my favorite way to go
with them personally is the seafood and
the steak I find it very hard to find
grass-fed beef uh and and Quality
Seafood uh in a supermarket uh or even
in a market devoted to those types of
products uh that's that's this
affordable and this convenient I like
all of it coming to my house it cuts out
another trip to the store it comes
Frozen very very beautifully freshly
sealed you know I means you throw it in
the freezer it's in there for a minute
you can keep it for a minute and then
when you're ready to eat it you take it
out and you do what you got to do and
you make your meal I love butcher box
it's convenient and it's affordable
that's all you can ask for these days
butcherbox also is going to give you a
special deal sign up today at
butcherbox.com
tastebuds and use promo code taste buds
to get $20 off your first order that's
pretty nice that's butcherbox.com
tastebuds and use code taste buds to
claim that
deal yeah you're right he's like you
know he's eight songs in he's like I
think I heard this girl like it's like
dude she's like dudes are just so
oblivious she went she went and wrote
her Masterpiece based off the emotional
trauma that he caused her and he was
like is this about me yeah yeah like
she's in a room pouring her heart out
and he's just like oh my God it's so
great how many times you think they got
into a heated argument he's like hey
come on now cut it out
cut yeah she's yeah they're in an
argument she's going hold on she's going
hold on hold
on what are you doing you cut it out no
you cut it out and imagine the Goon she
was with before him if she thinks that
he speaks eloquently you
know oh my god dude Jesus man that's uh
wait so wait can you pull up the lyrics
what I was just going to ask what we
should see how close we can get cuz I
think I can still nail them it's not
fair to remind me of the mess you left
when you went away it's not fair they're
not like that damning that's pretty bad
though dude of the crosy bear that you
gave to May May and by the way by the
way by the way she knew he didn't
know right yeah it's it's perfect he's
like I don't know if this is about me
but she's like I got something you want
to Fu know Budd that's deep right yeah I
mean it's right right there I want you
know she sing to all men she's like hey
guys you know you don't even know I want
you to know I'm happy for you I wish
nothing but the best for you both okay
so he moved on to someone who was her a
cheating situation we don't know an
older version of me is she perverted
like me okay she's implicating herself
as a pervert I like it she go down on
you in a theater does she speak
eloquently cuz she says she speaks
eloquently when she have your baby I'm
sure she'd make a is that sarcasm I sure
she'd make a really excellent mother
could be I think she's she's definitely
got chills reading the lyrics the lyrics
are really the love that you gave that
we made wasn't able to make it enough
for you to be open wide no and every
time you speak her name does she know
how you told me you hold me until you
died till you died but you're still
alive damn man that's a gangster lyric I
mean sing it and you're like you just
sing it but when you stop and read it
like it's a letter to him or something
got me chill this album like took over
it was the thing
she was the Taylor Swift of that time
dud my my dad is a dude who like he's
nuts like rides and Harley's it was
bench in like 315 back then that loved
this album yeah like you know what I
mean like this [__] crossed over it like
it attached to like the it was like
attached to like the the grunge thing so
I think it was like totally fine like
you know it wasn't like you know just
regular pop so I think people like kind
of was like for everybody you know she
had an edge to her I mean what are you
gonna you know so let's let's continue
this cuz this is sad you seem I will
stand by what I said as I read the
lyrics they're not that damning it just
sounds like somebody saying you told me
you'd love me forever you broke up with
me and it shattered me and um this is me
venting out the anger of that none of
it's like you're a cheater you're you're
abusive none of it's like that you know
but I still think that the way that she
articulated this it it it it kind of
implies How deep the wound was though
how bad breakup but she has a way with
words I'll tell you that much she also
calls him Mr duplicity in the in the
next see she says it's a SL the how
quickly I was replaced she's not saying
you cheated she's saying like you moved
on after me so quickly and I'm hurt by
it which is fair but it's not like I
don't think it makes him sound like a
bad
guy no but I think when somebody pours
their heart out like this and you're
like huh like it kind of makes you just
go with this person you know what I mean
it's hard to go with the guy who's like
I didn't even know that was happening
even in going with her my take would
just be like oh she's she's very hurt
and angry right now right it makes you
feel bad for her not hate him no yeah
exactly that's exactly it exactly I mean
compared to this day and age where
they'd be like I got an audio tape him
saying I'd grab her who yeah yeah can
you scroll to the last the last thing
she wrote a song about M Gibson down
down down okay right there right there
there and I'm here to remind you okay
you mess it's not fair to deny me of the
crosy bear that you gave so he's denying
her it so he doesn't he doesn't even
know okay and also she says in the
beginning it wasn't enough for you to be
open wide meaning like he just never
really like I think he was just like
yeah this is cool like whatever like he
didn't open up the way she was like the
lyrics to This these days like in this
day and age with the way [__] goes the
lyrics would be like the lyrics would be
like remember what you said about the
Jews remember when you said 12 wasn't
too young it would be so crazy you said
that
[Music]
was I can't say it here but it starts
with this is like I can't say the
word uh uh cuz the joke that you laid in
the bed that was me and I'm not going to
fade cuz the what does that mean cuz the
joke that you laid in the bed that was
me I don't know is that how it goes in
the bed that was cuz the joke that you
laid in the bed that was me that was me
she you made she made he made a joke out
of her okay he laid the joke she's the
joke and I'm not going to fade as soon
as you close your eyes and you know it
and every time I scratch my nails down
someone else's back I hope you feel it
well can you feel it wow it really feels
to me like this was something like she
was so and he kind of she knew that he
was just like oh it's cool like yeah
whatever like you know like he kind of
was just so like aloof about it and
that's what she's so hurt about is that
lopsided that he could be that aloof and
she the way he described her sweet
talented they had to have get to a
certain level of that relationship for
that to come out of her no no no here's
what I'm thinking you're thinking of her
as Alanis Moore said at the time he was
Uncle Joey she was just great Point she
was just a chick who was in love with
him he you know she was not this guy was
on the hottest worst sitcom that was
ever made yeah yeah he's he's living
large and he's by the way he's hanging
out with Stamos you think he's not
getting that Stamos fall off your and
this this is when being famous this is
when being famous meant something now
everyone all good points All Points he
was at the Forefront of that uh late 80s
early 90s fashion as well that that late
sag he had the mullet he had a shoulder
paded jacket that was a nice teal rest
his soul sagot God Rest his soul sagot
was at at a time pulling like Els you
know what I mean like these guys were
killing it yeah you were famous on the
sitcom period you know what I mean like
well what year did this come out this
song and then what year did Full House
stop because if in the ' 80s if you were
on like a box of cereal you were getting
tense so different you know what I mean
this song is yeah 95 what year did Full
House
end oh my God and that's a key word
there too guys Canadian he's Canadian I
bet as a standup he was already huge in
can in fact I think that's where they
shot all those early Nickelodeon shows
so he was already big okay he was
already the man then he breaks through
and he's like now I'm famous in the
states so she met that's big man she met
him what was what was his name in in the
show Uncle Joey Uncle Joey Joey so she
met him prior to that because uh Full
House ended in 95 and that's the year
that her that that song came out so she
was like she knew who Uncle Joey was
when she met him maybe we don't know how
long they dated for well we well I'm
just saying though this came out in '95
it's year she could have dated him since
'
84A she said when they were dating he
said when they were dating she was
writing this yeah but that could mean oh
wow 10 12 years but then she how old was
she despite a sizable age Gap atanas was
born in 74 Dave was born in 59 the par
dated for two years yeah so she was she
was what
21 and how long was H was Full House on
7 years8 years 21 when that album came
out right are you kidding me5 yeah I
thought she was like an adult know we
all thought she was 43 years old with
me I was 19 when that came out I had I
was 19 when that came out I had no idea
that she was like my age women were
women had a different breath about them
back then
yeah yeah I know I thought she was like
a college professor or something I
literally thought she was like a
30-year-old I looked at her as like I
didn't think that she was literally my
my equal like you know what I mean like
no wow maybe it's cuz she was also dated
him I I thought I don't know dude those
early Tori Amos records she's probably
like 19 when she put those things out in
the arms of and they sound they were
written by like a 67y old woman who's
traveled galaxies like the depth of
these people wow you know like uh and
and then honestly I don't know if he did
anything Dave did anything
like of of equal measure after that and
then and then she skyrocketed it would
be great if he was like in my uh well
you know I shot back uh turkey TV
was when I got Kirky TV that's what I
knew harose was C all right we should
get to the battle man we're running out
of some time I know like dishing yeah
yeah all right guys the battle today uh
is wow we got a good one man uh uh Rob
I'm so sorry I almost called you AJ I'm
really sorry and I'm not being
literally just almost called you a
happens all the time uh Rob said he
really came in strong with he loves
Shake Shack we were hesitant but then
you Googled you found out Shake Shack is
absolutely International we didn't know
God God B there was two of them like
five years ago it was a
shack um anyway uh so Rob is going to
take Shake Shack I explain it I
obviously said let's put McDonald
against it sou said enough already with
the McDonald's you need some you need an
adversary to go up them we have like
five guys here but I don't think I don't
know Five Guys is I think they're the
biggest fast casual but I said happily I
said I'll take Burger King yeah which is
nice because it's like it's the same
thing but different right like they're
elevated Burger King is an old school
staple they're a new school staple I
like it they both serve the same
products essentially yeah and I still
pledge my loyalty MC to McDonald's but I
absolutely love Burger King uh Burger
King like I said in the other room I'll
break a diet over Burger King craving
sometimes I love Burger King do you
remember back in the day when Burger
King like this is a long time ago when
they had the two little burgers that
were attached mhm do you remember that
oh my God you remember that bro oh my
God I haven't thought of that since it
was since we just brought this up I was
like oh my God you brought two and you
broke them is that what it was yeah I
can you Google that by any chance the
dude you just unlocked yeah yeah that's
how I felt at the same time roughly the
same time is when uh was sucking off KFC
was doing chicken littles do you
remember when KFC was doing chicken
littles and it was the little soft like
almost potato bun with the chicken patty
yeah the May oh they were so good this
was a this was a genius marketing move
maybe I don't know I I forgot about it
but I remember as a kid like yeah that
was a long time ago that was like that
was like more than 25 years
ago it might have been years ago we will
know wait a minute no I don't think this
is it is that Moses
storm do like just Google like attached
mini burgers Burger King or Burger King
mini
burgers oh duh
sliders no but that's not what it was no
this is what it is no it was like two I
think you could get a two pack or a four
pack or a
six-pack can you go up back and was this
like shots fired at Dwight Castle is
absolutely Burger King I got to tell you
Burger King's real low down with that
man they they took the yeah there we
go you know what's funny too is like
they all they did was like not break the
like the buttons come like that in the
package right they were like people like
this were being lazy lazy right they're
like we'll take one step out of the
equation if you look at it it's absurd
it's genius it's a way it's a way to to
feel like you're buying one burger that
has different elements to it ex said cuz
if they was like you know like it was if
they were separated like I'm not two
burgers I got to buy two burgers they
stole so they stole Burger King also
stole the Big King The Big Mac and they
called it the Big King right but that
was shots fired at McDonald's because
McDonald's stole the Whopper McDonald's
pulled the the ballsiest as I'm about to
defend Burger King McDonald's pulled the
ballsiest move in all of fast
food I love when you say something just
like that man it's unbelievable we have
no Authority but yeah no do you remember
they do you remember when they did the
mcdlt I I just want that to be true tell
it say it tell me it's true I want a
fact to be McDonald you know McDonald bu
you remember when they did the mcdlt
mcdlt McDonald's did the M DLT okay and
it was it was just it was a Whopper it
was all the Whopper ingredients right
and Burger King had always already
there's the package for it the two sides
right McDonald Burger King oh you
combine the sides right Burger King had
already firmly establish the laer
McDonald's comes down they go who wants
the cold stuff all wrapped in with the
hot stuff that's disgusting we're going
to make it where it's separate and then
you put it together idea you put it
together yourself they literally just
stole their burger and go made it better
was there it's s it was such a balls out
move uh it was you had to admire it you
had to admire it yeah I guess you can't
like
patent no it's it's lettuce and tomato
on a cheeseburger yeah oh my God what is
that real that's real that's fake that's
fake pimp no that was real I think
that's so disg no that was that's insane
that's like a welfare brick yeah you
can't right
youzy okay so we're looking at what is
called the Burger King uh the the real
cheese the real cheese burger and Burger
King had this
when uh it was 20 slices of cheese and
no meat this article came out in 2023
but this this didn't just come out in oh
you know what this is this is an answer
to In-N-Outs grilled cheese where they
just put a bunch of cheese on the bun
but 20 slices literally like that's not
good I mean the saturated I mean it's
literally like sure but I'm saying
that's what they're trying to do is an
answer Burger King will take your [__]
look at it and just look at
it I mean you can't even melt the cheese
all the way because you have to be B
tosos with that now we're you know man I
wonder I don't know I would love I would
like to eat it but like not be affected
by it and never have like like to see
what it's like I I like Oh and it was in
Thailand it was in Thailand it
said that's just but that's just it's
it's we're in a different day and age
now too right but like no well unless
this kids in you got to you got to
remember though it it just looks like a
thick grilled cheese it doesn't look
that bad he's look he looks sick from it
look at him look at him he's almost
puking um
so they that got through a boardroom of
people like it got through got through
the marketing company they hired it got
through all the top breasts at Burger
King someone said yes put 20 slices of
American cheese but in and out was
already doing it they weren't putting 20
though were they I've never had it in
out but I've seen the grilled cheese in
in out and I was like that's gross
that's just cheese slices on a hamburger
bun so Burger King just said hey they're
doing that so we'll do it and we'll make
it more extreme and people will go for
it because it's crazy I don't think that
odd of an idea I mean 20 is dis I do cuz
I think 20 is disgusting I but I also
think it's in the Wheelhouse of fast
food to pull a move like but even if you
say 10 like 10 is outrageous 10 is
outrageous becomes like when you make a
grilled cheese it's like three four
slices of cheese four is like four is
like you know I'll tell you that's a lot
I'll tell you what the 20 is the 20 in
my opinion the 20 is so it looks
substantial and they said how many do we
need to make it look like they're
actually getting something for their
money they said 20 and they go great
then we're going to Market it like isn't
this bad bat [__] that we're doing but
does it difference he substantial and
absurd and gross looking well he ordered
it raw too clearly he did not have that
melted they also made it into like
Jewish stars did you see that they yeah
they they had a little they had a little
do that's a dog whistle uh all right so
wait wait a minute so Rob we're going to
Sidetrack too much here on Burger King's
atrocities what what is it that you love
about Shake shf sha opening arguments go
to you please listen I just think when
you talk about Shak Shack and you
compare it to other places it's the
difference between going to a restaurant
or not like if I'm going to Burger King
I don't feel like I'm going to a
restaurant I feel like I'm going to a
gas station like somewhere that belongs
in a gas station gas station closest to
my house has a Burger King in it yeah
that's what I'm saying you feel you're
fine D dining at a Shake Shack not fine
dining few restaurants have the word
Shack in the title yeah or shake well
that's that's just because it started in
you know at a as a i a push cart can you
not make the joke literal please can we
just have I don't think it I
don't continue I'll poke holes anywhere
I want I'm Switzerland I don't when you
leave Shake Shack your clothes aren't
smelling like shake like you leave
Burger King someone could be like like
you just at Burger King you know what I
mean you kind of bring it with you there
is a musk at Burger King but it's one of
the things I like about Burger King I
like bur musk you like it I like that
every fast food place they all have it
McDonald's smells like they're fries
Burger King has the flame BR smell smell
yeah every Pizza Hut smells like Pizza
Hut like it's I don't mind that but
Shake Shack doesn't have a smell cuz
it's kind of real food they it's it's
real food so this is the this is where
you're going to have a hard time here
cuz Shake Shack is real food for the
home get Chris theano get Chris that pig
in here for when he pretends to be
homeless on the subway give him a
Whopper so the thing you're going to
you're going to need
Nostalgia and value and convenience to
come into play here in order to beat
because if you put them if you put them
head-to-head as far as food quality
there's no one making the argument that
Burger King's going to be a better
burger or have I think they do fresh cut
fries also don't even get me started on
the actual Shake menu which is really
nice you know I I rarely have a shake
but they have like five six flavors and
a shake in a burger is quintessential I
would listen throw onion rings at me too
you got those Burger got onion rings
yeah oh I'm sorry I'm sorry we don't
have they don't has onion rings I don't
know but the the onion rings at Burger
King are [__] great I will say this
about Shake sh they're just to they're
just bread crumbs yeah yeah it's just
straight up bread Rings amazing yeah
they they sometimes you bite them and
there's no onion most of the time you're
sh find ring yeah but I will say this
listen here's my thing with Shake
Shack and it is good don't get me wrong
I'm not saying it's not good uh but my
problem with Shake Shack is
this they
believe excuse me first of all I always
say the same thing when it comes to
Burger fast food I don't want it to
taste like I could make it at home I
wanted to have a little element of like
man this is weird like I don't know what
they do but it's weird own thing going
on yeah so that's the first part the
second part is has that for sure if you
get bad Shake Shack which does happen
and has happened to me really because
there's enough of them now that quality
control is not what it was when there
was only one in Madison Square Park
right there lot of shake Shacks now
getting bad Shake Shack is quite
possible getting bad Burger I don't know
about that hold on getting bad Burger
King is also quite possible here's what
sucks about get I can live with bad
Burger King you get bad shake your
expectations are here yeah but but and
you go and you go what did I spend $8
Shake Shack you get a bad meal you go I
just spent $23 and this sucked but but
give me an example of a Tom you got a
bad Shake Shack
meal about I will give you a couple
times they've all been the same thing
every time I've gotten it door Dash to
me it's it's been bad it it's not good
it's it's like it's just not good
doesn't travel well it's not that it
doesn't travel well it's just the P by
the way since they've expanded the
portions are going down it's just it's
just you get it delivered you go this
sucks like I could have made a better
version of this myself can you can you
make your argument based on delivery if
it travels well like that seems to it's
Nota it's not about travels well it's
I'm just saying when I've had it
delivered I'm not saying it shows up and
it's like soggy or it sucks I'm saying
like I'm just like this just isn't great
like like it wasn't made it wasn't put
together right and the reason I'm
putting the emphasis on delivery is
because I think there's too many Shake
Shacks now OG Burger King would be an
easy win but somewhere it all went wrong
so Shake sh look that's and that's
that's a comment from Anthony no
that to be honest I swear to God I
thought that's what it said at first not
that it was him or if it was an old
tweet I don't know but it's Anthony
Bowens our good friend who was just on
the pods a couple weeks ago thank you
for w oh Anthony a w Anthony I didn't
realize was I'm I'm completely banked
ranked Anthony you
mother he went against me too battle I
forget you battled um Denny's WAFF right
that's right won that that's tough
Waffle House won no no no Denny's won no
we're starting it again right now
apparently no Waffle House won bro no it
did not yes it did did it absolutely did
not it did it oh wait it
did you see what I put up with Rob it
absolutely did not this is why atore
said hates men yeah exactly right here
you know we reite
history this is what I I literally get
this at least once an episode he makes
he makes an absolute and he's you say
dumb you were going to say dumb you
could say dumb you I was going to say
you make a a a declaration you should
make a like a what do you call like a
collage of like all the time he's like
it
absolutely you know and you just show
52% I mean Shake Shack is kind of
sweeping up in the comments it's just
better food like I think if you go I
think and especially I think it's better
food for someone who like if you're
eating food all the like if you're
eating food like this all the time like
I think sometimes they have those videos
where like they take someone from
somewhere that's like never had fast
food and you give them stuff where like
for people who have been eating it their
whole lives I think when you have
something like Shake Shack it's
refreshingly good like where you're like
wow this is because the also the
explosion of those fast casual burger
joints like the Five Guys like the like
the Gordon rims like all those things
that's that's later on that didn't they
didn't have that when we were younger
right you know but I would say but
here's the thing man here's the thing
let's let's let's get down to the basics
of this argument the core of this
argument Burger King has cemented itself
in the animals of burger history the
Whopper period the Whopper period that
is second only to the Big Mac not even
Wendy's not even Wendy's could come up
with a burger bacon ater they came kind
of close but something that actually
holds a title belt in the burger fights
Shak Shack will never in a million years
have one thing where somebody goes you
go to Shake Shack for this well that's
because sh Shack is serviceable across
the board but you don't go I got to go
to Shake Shack for this one thing I go
dude I got to break my diet to get a
Whopper right now because it's it's a
Whopper it tastes like a Whopper I need
a an addiction it's that's true and
that's yeah because there's no other
taste like that you start to crave the
taste not necessarily the burger per se
the taste of the burger that sounds
weird I'm splitting hairs but you know
what you mean when you're biting into
that you're not getting that taste
anywhere else which is what you said but
I will say this um I I didn't think I
was going to say Shake Shack doesn't
Market that way right I I I from what I
recall it was a cheeseburger double
cheeseburger oh [__] they're trying to
look
trying pulled it up and I was like oh
wow they are pushing so you Shack Burger
spicy Shack Meister everyone's doing
Angus avocado bacon okay but that's not
really the shroom at the pathetic ham
look at that hamburger you're telling me
that looks like pimp pimp hold on stay
right there on hamburger and pull up a
picture of the M of just the regular
Burger King hamburger not the Whopper
they even have a grilled cheese just the
hamburger
that's the cheeseburger at Burger King
look at the cheeseburger at Shake Shack
yeah but hold
on now but now but now if we compared
the photo to what you get in your hand I
I've eaten a lot of bacon I've eaten a
lot of cheeseburgers from Burger King
that it tastes like that picture looks
no no but yeah but I'm saying it doesn't
look like the picture looks no it
doesn't it look somebody took that and
threw it at a windshield and then put it
back together you know they they they do
all the tricks when they photo grapping
that I think that shake Jack is like we
don't need to you've tasted our Burger
we you know we we don't need you're
talking to a man who fluff salami up in
a sandwich for a pH get it I get it I
understand what it means great Joe has a
sandwich shop and uh and Social club/
bar in the low E side it's called Joey
roses come do you drink oh I don't for a
10 old boring do you eat sandwiches
depends what we're talk I mean am I
breaking my thing for I try and be like
super healthy guy like you see very
healthy you
it's one of those things like when you
know if you get sober and you want to
like change your life and then I
couldn't be like sober and eating Burger
King cuz then I'd want to kill my you
know what I mean I'd want to [__]
drink you guys are Polar
Opposites I mean polar opposit you just
want to drink and eat sand listen he's
like I want to drink and eat sandwiches
so bad I'm going to make it my job right
and here and here's the thing from from
the outside we're complete opposites on
the inside same guy probably because
that's all I want to do I want to do is
drink and eat [__] fast food and this
but I see I would think the treat of not
see I still like to drink so that's why
I try to eat right now is because I'm
like you you can't do both all the time
but I would think if you're not drinking
your treat is you can eat some junk here
and there you but if I do eat junk I
want to eat junk that's like you know I
don't want to get into like all the [__]
but like you non GMO like I want to eat
something like I want to get junk from
Whole Foods like that kind of thing
where I'm like oh I when I wake up yeah
in the morning I can still go to the gym
like you know what I mean like if I eat
Burger King tonight I might be out for 3
Days yeah you no no joke that's going to
sit there and you're going to be
lethargic and all you know but but
listen listen if you walked in here
right now right and I had on a table uh
burger fries shake from Shake Shack or
or drink whatever and burger fries from
Burger King and you got to pick whatever
one you wanted you wouldn't choose Shake
Shack and a head to head right there
like you wait wait you you spoke so
quickly toward the end I I didn't catch
the tail end that say that
you you I was
reading let's call there was a blatant
disregard I was reading I was okay go
ahead go ahead but when you said you
have to lean heavily on Nostalgia that's
the thing it's like the real question
should be if you came in and had never
had Burger King and you tried Shake
Shack and tried Burger King what do you
think you'd say after because you don't
have the oh this reminds me I have all
those good times I stands to come close
I don't think it's a fair argument and
here's why I don't I think if you never
had any fast food and then you ate fast
food for the first time as a grown adult
you would be like wait what you know
what I me I don't know I still think the
Big Mac I still think if you're eating
if you go get a Big Mac even if it's the
first time you're like holy [__] like
this is I love a Big Mac but who
could who can tell because I've I've
been eating it for 30 some years like my
you know what I mean actually this is a
good idea put them put them head-to-head
all of them see Five Guys is what I
where I was going to tell you to go Five
Guys is is Five Guys is Sol actually
have you had Smash Burger never it is
really good smash yes really good that's
what I like I like a crispy like in out
can take a walk it's like one of those
you know like yeah I mean Inn out I I
think I out fries suck they're the worst
fries they taste stale they're terrible
they're worse than than uh Chick-fil-A
fries I don't like out has has the only
fry would call almost inedible why don't
they do something about that it seems to
be the popular opinion they cut them
fresh and they think it's good it's
terrible I don't know terrible you think
Carl's Junior belongs in this bracket
Carl's Junior's great I get it cuz they
kept all the fast food on the right and
they kept the fast casuals U I'm sorry
on the left and fast casual well Carl
Jun Carl Jr Big Buford or is that
Checkers the Big Buford is Checkers I
never heard of that yeah the Big Buford
it's it's it's the funniest name ever
for a burger ever oh oh so they're going
why does it say taste price atmosphere
are they trying to oh well
because because all of these places do
have their own Vibes which I will say
with Shake Shack I don't care for Burger
King there's a warmth you go in there
it's inviting that's from the the Open
Flame but is is that is that is that
because it does it have a warmth because
it reminds you of the younger you're
younger no there's just something
comforting there's something there's
something about Shake Shack where you
walk in you feel like like it's like not
really supposed to be there it's there's
going to be a line they want you to get
out of the place can't just say words
bro I you walk the Shake Shack and feel
I'm not supposed to be here if you I
always felt like that in Shake Shack I
have never felt comfortable if you go up
to somebody if you take somebody who's
never been to a Burger King and you
bring them in and you go do you feel the
warmth I think you're getting a no bu
the yeah now we get into it the slogan
they say when you walk to the register
you
you're a sucker for marketing dude they
got you a hook line and sink they let
you know right off the bat we're here
for you Shake Shack never felt very
welcome Shake Shack feels like when you
go to like Pat Stakes or goino stakes in
Philly there's there there's a line it's
like move do you know what you want
hurry up it's New York don't waste
anybody sou it feels a little bit like
that it used to now there's propaganda I
hope you're not on like Tik Tok because
propaganda is got you they'll make you
oh they got right in his his head look
at this what is this the illusion of
free choice Burger King Shake Shack Joe
prises McDonald's that's very funny oh
that's so funny that's great you can
drink it Shake Shack yes you can I
didn't even know that I've had a date or
two at Shake
Shack wow you didn't bring her to the
warm cozy place you to the place that
bring you to Shake Shack and a drink at
the you got to you got to impress her I
got to take her to the fancy
restaurant
in we should see if we could can make
that a shirt that'd be a good shirt
that's fun that's fun yeah uh oh that's
my my boy Jack Jack always hits home
runs uh pimp how we doing on time all
right let's let's just a couple phones
phones we go to we call them the phones
we go here we read we read uh what the
what people are saying why dine in a
shack when you can dine with a king
metchley for the win that is the winning
tweet today oh you've been tweeting this
out the whole time oh oh yeah we tweet
the poll oh I didn't know you were
tweeting it out the whole time so this
is live they're they're voting live oh
now that makes a lot of sense we will
know a winner based on them you know
fantastic yes absolutely Burger King is
terrible that was straight into the
point couple syllables all I needed I'm
seeing a lot of that like I don't even
know Shake Shack but I'll still vote for
it cuz I hate Burger King I'm seeing a
lot of that dude if you're on a road
trip and you see a Shake Shack it's like
wow like it's like oh thank God yes yes
it's not you're not going to the rest St
and getting like the burger that's under
the heat lamp I'm not no I disagree they
make Burger King on the spot I'm not mad
at a Shake Shack but I'm not I'm not as
excited about it as you guys let's read
some of these okay Shake Shack easy it's
pretty new to Texas but Burger King is
trash the cheese fries already beat batk
by themselves I truly believe no one
genuinely likes Burger King it's just
McDonald's haters coping yeah and
Nostalgia I think it's a lot of
nostalgia King is a sin The Shack is
overrated but I will note they use
crinkle cut yes they do and their cheese
fries are great Burger King burgers are
ridiculously large that's a pro in my
book I agree with that the weight of a
Burger King meal in the bag I've gotten
Shake Shack I'm not kidding I have spent
$30 at Shake Shack and walked out with
multiple sandwiches and fries and felt
like I was carrying nothing back that
bothers me man that bothers me slowly
slowly up no the other way just slow the
other way just slow the other way yeah
yeah just a little more a little more
cuz there was something there little
more a little more a little more there
it is it's the Royal House of burgers
versus a greasy milkshake Shack all hail
the king I just wanted to give a little
bit of thank you you know back you know
got to be BK never heard of Shake Shack
Shake shak's burgers are better but
their shakes are just average and
overpriced voted BK for the overall menu
that's true too BK's overall is is is a
winner I was unaware though of that
shake Jack menu that was that was pretty
uh ambitious because because they
franchised out now and it's or or at
least chained out I don't know if it's
franchises or not but it's too is there
a quality contr control problem with SH
Shack that I absolutely think so that's
why I was saying when I get it delivered
I don't think it's cuz of delivery I
think it's cuz there's too many kitchens
making it and it's not good anymore fell
off a little they lost a step yeah and
you see what they're doing they're
trying now to step into into into the
fun fast food gaming and with those
prices you ain't doing it Shack
definitely don't want Burger King foot
lettuce how about that it's ironic that
walking into a Burger King feels like
you're walking into a sh that's very
funny that's that's uh that's a good one
all right one more and then let's go to
the
vote Ramsey what this is like comparing
actual human feces to a Gordon Ramsey
handmade meal Shake Shack every single
time all right all right let's go to the
vote Humble Pie segment here right now
please do your plugs and the way this
win works is you do your plugs we click
and see who votes whoever wins says to
the loser I still love you you say I
love you back so but plug whatever you
want yeah I do a uh podcast with Jam Lin
Ziggler who played my sister on Sopranos
it's called not today pal we do it with
uh y
MH uh yeah that's really you know that's
seor network if you guys don't know
we'll come on your show when we're down
please yeah down in Austin and you know
what's funny when we were like when we
were first talking about doing the show
like well what do you want to do the
show about and I'm like I don't want to
pigeon hole myself to talk about one
thing but if it was one thing it'd be
food like right just I could just
[__] talk about food all day dude
you're a great guest man thanks
sometimes when people come in cold and
don't even know the show we don't know
if they'll be able to like really grasp
like what like what we're what we're
going for here but you've I mean spot on
my best friend's girlfriend I used to be
like tell Rob I said hi and she'd be
like how do you always know it's CU you
guys talk about food for three hours on
the phone like we'll just be on the
phone talk about and it's like you and
you guys order the same thing every
night we order from the same [__]
come back you got to come back too all
pimp pimp is going Shake Shack here we
got 4200
votes uh oh wow wow very close actually
Shake Shack takes the W very nice Our
Guest wins
54.8
54.6% to Burger King's
45.4% that's a close toilet that's a
close match actually 4200 people on a
Tuesday afternoon shout out to work from
home I just want to say um that I mean
that is close yeah that is and we only
put this up like 40 minutes ago I
thought Burger King would take it I I
you know I really if you would have told
me before this I really wouldn't
wouldn't be able to have sometimes I'm
like definitely this one but because
they're so different and because Burger
King is around so much longer and has so
much more of like people who have
probably tried it but Shake Shack man
Burger King's done so much more for this
country shout outs to the Sneak King
Xbox video game that they made oh the
crown you didn't even bring up the crown
us the fown we were kind of knocking a
Nostalgia aside and I was trying to not
go back in the day too much I was trying
to stick to like what's happening now
anyway good win dude thank you just oh
still no he says it I you say good win
okay yeah no I say good win yeah I still
love you I still love you
too taste bus they com to the mic
talking about the they hate talking
about the they like two fools going to
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they coming to the